if you look at males it turns out that
in a number of animals males who have a
relatively broad face are more
aggressive there was a Canadian team
that looked at hockey teams and looked
at the number of minutes that individual
players spent in The Penalty Box for
being too aggressive there was a
positive relationship between breadth of
the face and the number of minutes spent
in The Penalty Box
right to say that humans are an
aggressive species do you think
well yes in some ways we are incredibly
aggressive because we are responsible
for more deaths of members of our own
species than is typical of other animals
and yet at the same time of course you
know the great Paradox about us is that
in some ways we're just incredibly nice
and tolerant and friendly and
unaggressive
um and for years we grappled with how to
resolve these two contrary sides of our
personality but we cannot deny that part
of us is uh is a really aggressive
streak and we're seeing it at the moment
in in wars that occur around the world
and
um and those of course have gone on
throughout history
what does it suggest about
human nature or what our role is or what
would be adaptive for us that we seem to
be very effective at the barbell ends of
aggression
well you know one of the great questions
about human nature for uh two or three
hundred years has been are we
biologically
predisposed to be aggressive or are we
biologically predisposed to be tolerant
are we a an inherently aggressive
species that is tamed by Society or are
we an inherently tolerant unaggressive
species that is made aggressive by
Society
and you know my view and I think
increasing view is that that's that
question is misconceived you know
because the answer is that we're both or
neither if you like that whether or not
you look at our
our tremendous capacity and even
interest in committing
um aggression
uh or whether you look at our tolerant
aversion to aggression
both of them are part of our biology so
I think that what we're learning about
ourselves is that we have to recognize
that we are a mixture
and Society is not responsible either
for taming us or for making us the the
sometimes horrible species that we
sometimes are
you know this is us take us or leave it
who were the two philosophers that had
this big push was one
it wasn't Foucault who was the one who
was the French guy went and lived Russo
that was it sounds like yeah yeah
writing just uh just before the French
Revolution uh at the end of the 18th
century
um and um and and you know sort of very
ironic really you know because he has
become associated with the notion that
we are inherently non-violent and of
course everyone had such high hopes for
the French Revolution and then you know
there's this wonderful charitable uh
exotic new dawn of humanity turns into
the guillotine and uh and then you know
Napoleon uh and so on you know the
disaster that
um that befell uh the the the sort of
growing sense of civilization uh in
Europe at that time and then the other
great philosopher so so Russo is
associated with the notion that that
humans are inherently
um unaggressive
Are Made made aggressive by society and
uh and then the opposite side was Thomas
Hobbes who was living in the time of the
English Civil War uh in the second half
of the uh 17th century and uh and he was
impressed by the fact that uh you really
had to lock your door and you had to
worry about who your neighbors were
because they might come and kill you and
you know the Civil War was a terrible
thing and so he was associated with the
notion that uh there is something just
inherently competitive uh cruel violent
about humans and that what you need to
be able to control them is a Superior
Body a a an ultimate Authority he called
it a leviathan we would now think about
it as the state you know at that time
might have been the the monarch
um to keep everybody under control
and and you can look at both of these
these great philosophers who have been
representing these two opposing views
you know superficially opposing views
and think that in many ways both of them
were right
you know they they had a lot to them and
that's that's why people have sort of
supported one or the other over these
years
but um
uh you know the wonderful thing is that
we can now put the uh the nature of
human nature into a much broader
perspective than ever was done by
political philosophers who are basically
of course sitting in their armchairs you
know I mean from the point of view of
modern science they weren't trying to to
really figure out what was going on in
terms of the wet biology or in terms of
our evolutionary relationships but we
can do that now and and we can look at
our close relatives uh the great apes
and we can see elements of uh
all these two contrasting types of
behavior in our cousins and the
fascinating thing about that is not that
we can
say oh well you know we have inherited a
particular kind of quality from a
particular kind of ape but instead what
we can see is that Evolution Works in in
a fascinating ways to generate in one
species a certain level of uh some kinds
of aggression and another species are
different kinds of aggression and we can
figure out that there is a logic to The
evolutionary history
that leaves us deposited in our case on
the 20th century or 21st century
um with a particular set of inherent
Tendencies what do you think is the
evolutionary story of
humor what we are now are uh ancestors
journey through aggression
I think that we have to look back at the
last two million years which is the time
that we have been members of the genus
homo you know just around two million
years ago is when the genus homo arose
when for the first time you've got a
creature
that uh could walk into a a clothes shop
on Main Street and take clothes off the
peg you know they were our size and
shape
um they were a smaller brand they were
much more robust uh they were you know
big great big Beverages and great big
broad faces uh but they were they were
an early kind of human two million years
ago
and I think that for the whole of the
two million years
they were a species that were like
wolves or chimpanzees or a few other uh
species in being
very good Hunters
and also
very good killers of your own species
because once you once you're a good
Hunter you're like a lion or a wolf or a
chimpanzee
then it means that you can hunt anything
and if you go on a hunt a member of your
own species you're pretty good at that
that Weaponry can be turned inward yes
yes and it's not literally Weaponry in
the sense of uh of a spear you know is
the weapons of your claws and your and
your brain and your mouth and and
whatever it is and and in the case of of
actually all the species I mentioned
the really important weapon is a
coalition it's your gang it's ganging up
for five of us against one of you
because when you do that then you make
yourself safe
and none of these hunters will go out on
their own and try and attack you know a
wolf doesn't go out in and trying to
attack a bison on its own you know it
knows perfectly well that'd be
incredibly dangerous thing to do but if
you have 10 wolves and one bison well
now you're talking
you know someone can nip the wall the uh
it's uh rear end while the others are
confronting it at the front and so on
you know there's great advantage in
numbers and that is the way that humans
have always tended to attack and kill
other humans
it's through the advantage of numbers or
surprise or other tactical Arrangements
um that enable them to kill safely so if
you're asking what is the evolutionary
story of human aggression
I think the story that carries all the
way through to
to Modern Warfare
is that we were good at hunting and we
turned the hunting ability against
members of our own species when it
suited us to do so
and just you know we see this in war
nowadays because War consists of
a series of asymmetric attacks
we bomb their side
data they'd bomb us
it's an asymmetric attack in the sense
that it's a pretty premeditated planned
attack when it's pretty safe for the
attackers
what's not safe is what happens later
when they attack us
so that's one kind of aggression
wolf like chimp-like lion-like
that's humans throughout
the period of the genus homo
the other kind of aggression
is something that is
um
probably uh
the big event that changed everything
happened around three or four hundred
thousand years ago
and this is the invention of or the
development of a sufficiently skilled
language
that groups of men
were able to kill members of their own
group using that same
coalitionary ability that same gang
but the huge complication
when you are forming a gang against a
member of your own group is
how the Dickens do you know
that the ones that you hope are going to
be in your gang aren't going to turn
against you and you as say the
instigator of a gang let's go and get
that guy
might suddenly turn out to be the victim
and they all turn against you
the the quotationary Dynamics become
terrifying if you are trying to organize
a group against a member of your own
group is different from when you're
attacking a member of another group
because then you can all agree we hate
the members of that other group
but the emotions are mixed when you're
talking about individuals within the
same group and the solution to that
is sufficiently good language
where individuals can talk to each other
and get a real sense of reassurance
slowly developing you know just floating
an idea so you know that guy is a bit
weird recently don't you think you know
and um eventually getting
confidence that yes okay let's agree you
know he really deserves to be sent back
to the witches
um and we'll get him
and we'll all agree and that's it now
this ability to execute another member
of your own group
changes Society hugely because until
then
almost unimaginably for humans as we
grow up in society today
we would have had a really bullying
system
I mean maybe it is imaginable if you
remember High School
you know where there is some guy at the
top who really throws his weight around
you know I mean not all high schools are
like this but it does happen from time
to time and um
I throw his weight around and you know
he takes advantage of his his ability to
physically dominate everybody else uh
all animals do this basically you know
all the primates the chimpanzees and the
gorillas even the bonobos
um uh all the monkeys you have some Top
Male and he takes out on everybody else
and what is it what does he get he gets
well the females
and he gets the majority of the mating
he gets the best food he gets into
fights a lot of course but um
but he really just bullies everybody
and once you get
this ability to form a coalition that
can
kill
a bully in your group
then all of a sudden
Everything Changes
because nobody dares to be the bully
that exerts his power the Tyrant that
takes everything for himself
and all of a sudden
uh you get changes in society and then
slowly you get changes in the evolution
of our aggressive tendencies
and what you're doing
when you take out these bullies
is you are uh doing to humans
what Farmers have long done to
domesticated animals or to wild animals
as they became domesticated
you are selecting inadvertently in the
case of humans
for
the non-bullies for the less aggressive
individuals and at this point we have to
stop just take a breather and say
there are two kinds of aggression
in animals in general
humans are no exception
that have very distinctive Dynamics
and the one we first talked about the
one that is involved in hunting
is a premeditated form of aggression
which is not necessarily involved in the
emotions very strongly at all it's a
very deliberate kind of aggression
saying to herself
that I have a goal I want to go and kill
that animal or that person I want to go
and steal that gold and if I have to
kill someone to do it I'll get it
and then the other kind of aggression so
that was called proactive premeditated
predatory
the other kind of aggression is reactive
it's when
you as a man uh come into your home
bedroom and find another man in bed with
your wife
and you just lose it
this is not premeditated thoughtful
unemotional this is impulsive it's
defensive it's reacting to a threat and
you just lash out and and uh you you
you're a very emotionally aroused
and the aim here is to just get rid of
that threat
chase the guy out of the bedroom window
kill him
do whatever
and it turns out that these two kinds of
aggression proactive and reactive
are somewhat different in the way that
they are controlled in the brain
and they can be
following different evolutionary
trajectories
so you can maintain a high level of
proactive aggression and have a
selection acting against
your reactive aggression and that's what
happened in humans starting about three
or four hundred thousand years ago
when
um proactive aggression kept going we
had great hunters all the time but
reactive aggression started going down
we became much less reactive in our
aggressive tendencies how do we know
that how do we know that date it's
beautiful
when you select a domestic a wild animal
and choose to have
the successive Generations being those
that are are
the result of breeding by the less
aggressive the less reactively
aggressive individuals
then they show elements of
um some quite surprising
biological traits
and these we know these traits very well
because they occur in domesticated
animals all these different
lines of domesticated animals uh
unrelated Lions dogs cows goats cats
they all tend to have white patches of
fur on them
why do the white patches of fur
it's not because a farmer needs to have
a cow that's got a white patch on its
forehead or a horse that's got white
toes
these just occur spontaneously we know
this now because
there's this wonderful
Russian experiment starting in the 1950s
by a guy called Dmitry belaf
and he started breeding foxes
and lo and behold within a few
Generations the fox has got white
patches of fur on them
why is that it's because the foxes he
chose to breed were the ones that were
least aggressive
he would walk towards the foxes when
they were about six weeks old when they
were you know just just young ones
um he would write down the distance that
the human would get within the fog with
a as they approached the fox when the
fox said
that was it reacting
and then he would breed from the ones
that allowed the humans to get closest
the least reactively aggressive
and in 10 Generations they got white
patches of fur hello
there's something mysterious going on
here and we're beginning to get a handle
on what it is about the biology that
says
when you select against reactive
aggression
you develop these symptoms of the
domestication syndrome like white
patches of fur another one is floppy
ears
there is no wild animal actually there's
there are there's only one kind of wild
animal that has floppy ears do you know
what it is elephant yes very good nailed
it
boom uh that's that's what Darwin
pointed out he said but all the
domesticated animals you will find some
individuals and some some groups that
have got floppy ears
um and uh the floppy ears uh yeah
they're associated with young ones in
wolves but in in many dogs they retain
those floppy ears all the way through an
adulthood into adulthood so this is a
another feature of the domestication
syndrome
well now obviously humans don't have
floppy ears
um
I'll wait for
well um we don't often have white
patches of fur
but um
but there are some
features of the domestication syndrome
that are associated with our bones
and they are things like
relatively uh slender light boned
compared to our ancestors
shorter faces
smaller chewing teeth
males becoming more female-like
and guess what all of these things
started happening
around 300 000 years ago
and just became more and more developed
with time
and so that's why we can say that was
selection against reactive aggression
starting at that time and that's why
we've ended up
relatively reduced in our tendency for
reactive aggression unlike our
very well maintained unfortunately
tendency for proactive aggression okay
let's let's recap The Story So Far So
humans are ancestors develop the ability
to first off uh coalitionally hunt that
then allows them to take down bigger
prey that is something which can get
turned inward but for the next one and a
half million years you have the problem
of a little bit more you have the
problem of coordination up until about
400 to 300 000 years ago when you get
language especially Advanced language
you have the ability to coordinate more
effectively not only do you have the uh
literal weapons of the size and the
shape and the fists and the teeth and
now the tools that we've been using the
Spears and the arrows perhaps but you
also have the ability to plan in advance
to be able to also gauge the reliability
of your other coalitional members and to
be able to say right we're going to take
him down because he's being a dick so
yeah it's time it's time for him to go
what that ends up happening is a
self-domestication of humans by humans
where the most aggressive mostly males
I'm going to guess will be pruned off
the top the ones that are too tyrannical
end up being executed by the remainder
of the group what this means is that
those ones some of them very well may
have ended up reproducing before they
were executed but on average you're
going to have a lower level of
reproduction from those individuals and
if they have sons that like the
aggressive Sun hypothesis I suppose if
you have aggressive Sons they are more
likely to be killed before they have
sons and so on and so forth which means
that over time the most aggressive males
are removed now this is a relatively
short period of time you know 300 000
years ago doesn't sound like long for us
to have been doing this but as you've
identified in only the space of between
five and ten generations of foxes you're
able to see a pretty rapid
anatomical change in regards to the
foreign
this is met with certain anatomical
changes in humans which includes
shortening of the face less aggressive
uh less powerful jaws less large teeth
reduced brow Ridge I'm going to guess
and then you said that men or males
became more female-like which I'm going
to guess means less muscle mass overall
lower bone density
etc etc so for the burgeoning
professional athletes amongst us maybe a
little bit unhappy that those males were
selected out of the group and you know
we see this with the difference in
strength between ocean chimps right that
a chimp could easily rip a human limb
from limo so I've heard uh and that
means that we have very much not only
um adapted to the selective pressures
outwardly that the environment gave to
us but almost kind of adapted to the
selective pressures that we placed on
ourselves socially through this
execution is that about right yes
absolutely exactly yeah so so we have
been very responsible for our own
evolutionary trajectory uh for the last
you know quarter of a million years and
more and and you say you know it all
seems to be relatively recent and is
true but of course we we have an
excellent fossil record and so you know
we know very well that there have been
these changes going pretty continuously
for the last quarter of a million years
and more
how can you talk about psychological
changes compared with our ancestors
who are no longer around it's not like
you can study our ancestors 300 000
years ago you can see the anatomical
changes but even those are mostly wasted
away apart from what's left in terms of
bone and teeth structure how can you
talk about the implied psychological
changes
well I mean the only way we can really
do it confidently is through this
correlation with the bones and there are
some correlations that are still very
fascinating today I mean one of them is
uh concerns the breadth of the face
uh in relationship to the length of the
face
and uh it turns out that
uh in in a number of animals and humans
is one of them
uh if you look at males males who have a
relatively broad face are more
aggressive
and there have been a bunch of studies
which show that this is true for humans
nowadays
so it's oh you are the breadth of our
faces has been reduced is become in
males more female-like
relatively narrow faces uh here's a
lovely example of a study
um which I think makes a couple of
important points
um there was a Canadian team that looked
at
ice hockey as we would call it or hockey
is it was recorded in the states
um uh looked at uh a number of
College hockey teams and a number of
professional hockey teams
and looked at the number of minutes that
individual players spent in The Penalty
Box
for being too rough being for being too
aggressive
and of course it's interesting to think
about this because uh you know what
we're going to see is that the players
who had broader faces spend more time in
The Penalty Box on average
but the referees are not really
particularly aware of this because
they've got helmets on so you can't you
know you it's difficult to even know
like it's prejudiced by the referees
against the broad-faced community right
exactly that's right an important point
in this study was that for each of the
study each of the teams that they looked
at
there was a positive relationship
between breadth of the face and the
number of minutes spent in The Penalty
Box but in no case was it significant
statistically significant
those who say it's not a very strong
relationship uh within each team but in
every team it happened every college
team and every professional team I think
it was a a total of 12 teams so the
overall significance was very clear
but you cannot look at in an individual
man and say yeah you know you've got a
broad face we know that you are an
aggressive type you're going to punch me
yeah right yeah wow it's a trend you
know okay so what is you mentioned about
the changes that would have happened
with regards to mostly male to male
aggression
what is interesting or is there anything
that you know about changes which
occurred to females were females self uh
domesticated at all throughout this
period
you know it's it's uh it's harder to
know I mean we don't have the same kind
of uh evidence concerning females so
you're saying that the uh female from
300 000 years ago would have been able
to walk into the department store and
Garner fewer looks perhaps than the male
because on average they would have
changed less is that right to say
well
um we'd have to give her a makeover
before she went in obviously yeah
um
what we don't have with females is
um the equivalent evidence of the
changes that were happening in males
independent of the males
you know it seems to me very likely that
females were indeed much more sort of
independent um uh aggressors
in those days
um but we don't know the reason I say
that is because
in some ways females have changed
particularly strongly compared to
um our sort of apish past compared to
males you know the males are still
a little bit more brutish
um a little bit less refined a little
bit hairier
um
a little bit more like our apish
ancestors and and they you know the
early forms of homo
so females in many ways changed
particularly strongly they've become you
know feminization has really changed
them from
um
from what they probably were which was a
much more uh male-like uh set of
individuals
but but we don't have at the moment
um any kind of really clear story
involving how would that happen it was
that just a an incidental consequence of
selection on males it doesn't seem very
likely but it's a theoretical
possibility
um or was there intense selection on
females to become less aggressive
themselves that could well well be the
case
so interesting because the ability the
male male ability to coordinate
more complex coalitions to physically
take down a male would have had a
similar impact on female capacity to
form coalitions I've been learning a lot
about intersexual competition your Joyce
beninson's of the world and so on and so
forth have been on the show a lot and um
the female capacity for gossip and
Coalition making breaking backbiting
venting and all the rest of it is
otherworldly and
it it has to have been the difference as
well between the way that males display
um Power struggles aggression
um the compete competitions for status
who it is that they're concerned about
with State it's the fact that men are
positively
um inclined toward a member of their
group who is stronger than them or
better than them at a thing because
typically that Coalition would have met
well if we've got to go take down that
Mammoth together Richard you look like
you've got a good set of biceps on you
that means that we can you can grab it
and I'll get it with the spear up I
don't know how you take down a mammoth
um the women on the other hand have such
an unbelievable Divergence in the way
that they go about things so it seems
like it would make sense to me that this
increased coordination coalitional
capacity would have caused women during
that period as well to have opened up a
whole new world of uh
changes yes for sure yeah and it's it's
very plausible there's another dynamic
as well which is that uh the evolution
of patriarchy
what do you mean that well
uh humans I think can be thought of as
having two kinds of patriarchy
uh one is the the sort of more
individualistic the type that occurs in
uh animals where a male can beat up on a
female just because he's bigger than her
because he's stronger
uh he can dominate her
but there's another type as well and
that is uh what you might call
institutional patriarchy
well within the group
There are rules that develop in the
society as a whole
that benefit men at the expense of women
what would be an ancestral example of
one of those
[Music]
you could say
um that uh
females who have adulterous relationship
are going to be punished more heavily
than males who do
which is something that happens pretty
much universally you know across
societies
it's a it's extremely common and you
never get it in the other direction
you never find that males are punished
more heavily than females
so you know I think what's going on here
is that you have an alliance among the
males
they don't like it when females are
adulterous because each of the females
belongs
to a particular male let me fold a very
interesting piece of information that I
learned a couple of weeks ago I want to
say that this was
maybe Christina Durante or someone else
who taught me that
women
condemn promiscuity more
the more sons that they have
because they want the male parental
uncertainty
they want to tune that down so women who
have sons show an increased uh distaste
for promiscuity and I thought that that
was absolutely fascinating so yes
absolutely I wonder how much it's just
uh it's just the men that would have
been behind the condemnation of the
promiscuous women I mean you know you
roll intra sexual competition into this
and you say well I have a man what we
actually want to do in almost like a
form of capital punishment to be able to
show this is what happens if you do that
now if you were a single woman that's
one fewer competition uh one for your
competitor within your mating market for
a future potential mate and if you are a
partnered up woman that would be one
fewer potential competitor for your
existing mate and if you're a woman who
has sons that is one fewer potentially
promiscuous male parental uncertainty
inducing partner for one of your sons so
I actually think that there might be
some motivation for women here as well
yeah yeah and then if if a woman has
daughters then she would quite like her
daughters to be able to have the choice
of
um you know choosing which man she has
for which which baby promiscuous women
have got I mean aside from the whole
slut-shaming thing uh
it's there are a lot of
pressures
from pretty much everywhere
and a lot of incentives from both men
and women ancestrally and in the modern
world to really I mean that's not to say
that that isn't against male promiscuity
too but it definitely seems like uh yeah
there's a lot of pressure for for women
to tune down that promiscuity
yeah and and I mean so when you had um
men
taking it out on the tyrant
I take in other words taking it out on
the alpha male uh by ultimately killing
him I mean so they're controlling
anybody who is taking more than his fair
share
of the females which until then he
always did as the alpha male you know
the alpha chimp takes a big share of
paternity but after that then
um it's a really important feature of uh
belonging to the alpha Alliance that
every male gets a female what's the
alpha Alliance the alpha Alliance is is
what I call the the group of males who
are responsible for
um killing the Tyrant uh okay okay
so they they become the leaders of the
the society
and and of course once they have
discovered that they can kill the tyrant
then that means they can kill anybody
including each other
including each other so so there's this
tremendous
um selection for in favor of conformity
in favor of all the emotions that show
that you are part of the Gang
um but also it imposes tremendous
pressures on females
because from now on
any female who goes against the Norms
that are imposed by the alpha Alliance
is going to be vulnerable to herself
being executed
and and you you see you know horrendous
accounts in uh the hunter-gatherer
ethnographies of the
19th and 18th centuries
where people were still getting glimpses
of what it was really like to be hunting
others before the missions had come in
and the governments had come in to to
get rid of all of the
um more
uh violent forms of of interaction
and and you get these stories of you
know a woman who
um has
a committed adultery uh she gets killed
a woman who has even seen the sacred
trumpets of the men
killer what's what do you mean what
sacred trumpets well men often have
rituals that
um are associated with the reasons or
the justifications for males being
dominant over females
uh so uh you know the sacred trumpets uh
you know these are things that literally
you can't find in particular societies
but they're iconic of uh the the
justifications that men produce
uh you know why why should the why
should you men you know always get the
the best food
right which they tend to do
they they the the meat uh the females
will get some but the males will get the
best the best opportunities
why should it when the men get well you
know that's all the gods say
who said that God said that
we go off and we talk to the god the
sacred trumpet trumpets I see so
this this is what particularly interests
me that we were sort of moving now from
the realm of individual uh anatomical
psychological and then societal
civilizational changes into morality now
we're kind of moving ourselves across
into values and virtues and what is
upheld and how the interplay of all of
this works
foreign
thinker well actually how how has this
impacted morality how how did these
changes inform the evolution of human
morality in your view
I think that uh the emergence of what
I'm calling the alpha Alliance the the
gang that is able to control the tyrant
uh is essentially simultaneous with the
evolution
of
um
of moral principles that are based on
the concept of right and wrong
so there's a kind of morality of
sympathy that you see a little bit
developed in the higher primates and and
maybe dolphins and so on uh where there
is a tendency for individuals just to
understand to be empathic towards uh
another individual who is suffering
and some people call that morality and
that's fine you can call him morality
but it's not on morality based on the
principles of right and wrong
morality is based on the principles of
right and wrong
is much more arbitrary
the right and wrong varies among
different societies what is right and
what is wrong
and I think the way to think about it is
that once you have a Power Group the
alpha Alliance
that is capable of executing anybody in
the group
and are therefore able to impose on the
group
their ideas about what benefits them
from a selfish perspective
what they do is to say here is Right
behavior and here is wrong Behavior
you know right behavior is and then
they'll lay out a series of things that
are good for the group as a whole like
we're not going to steal from each other
anymore okay
anybody caught stealing we're going to
punish you if you carry on doing it
you're dead
but they also have a different kind of
moral principle as well which is
purely selfish not just good for the
group as a whole but good for the men
if there's any problem with the food
supply the men get the first choice
if we find that a man and a woman have
been having sex that is outside uh
let's call it marriage
well
man can be understood but the women
that's no good
so I think that there are
the morality begins with the concept of
right and wrong
right and wrong is the result of what
benefits
the alpha Alliance the group that can
get rid of anybody can kill anybody
because they have that ability to talk
about it and do it
and there are those two ways in which
they think of right and wrong one is
what's good for the group as a whole and
the other is what's good for the men
and the reason that it would be adaptive
for everybody within a group to conform
to that is that anybody who decides to
transgress it is going to pay a very
high individual price yeah so yeah in
your in your view does that mean that
our sense of right and wrong is
basically us
working out how to be of how to avoid
being killed by small groups of alpha
males
pretty much exactly right
there are moral philosophers that are
throwing themselves off Bridges at the
moment hearing this thinking no it's
good there must be more
well
um
I I think you know this is a an area of
discussion that has not been you know
sufficiently aired at the moment
um but I feel very very comfortable
thinking that this all derives from
power dynamics
that uh that the the sense of right and
wrong is ultimately a sense of how to
protect yourself
from this
um evolutionary novelty
which is the fact that individuals can
be killed at very low cost to The
Killers
do you have any inclination
but is there any suggestion that this
sense of right and wrong exists outside
of culture
that you know is it that each generation
must learn what is right and what is
wrong and you or is there something
which is embedded in US genetically
which gives us an inclination toward
this too
or a predisposition perhaps well I mean
we're clearly very conformist
uh as a as a species
um and you know children uh at a very
young age uh learn to conform and they
learn to impose rules on each other and
or that when I say learn to you know
they do it almost spontaneously so that
certainly suggests that the you know the
basic Norm psychology is uh it's being
called uh has been inculcated into us
but what you're asking uh Are there
specific versions of what's right and
wrong uh and
um I'm not I'm not convinced about that
you know that there might be uh
something like
um
involving theft is some very basic
principles uh involving harming each
other
but but most of these things are subject
to some kind of fluidity yeah so I guess
some sort of inherent feeling of
fairness uh maybe
um like discussed aversion or your
discussed threshold stuff like that you
know if you were to do something that
made you feel very traumatized yourself
you know the fact that uh soldiers deal
with things like PTSD
would be pretty maladaptive if we were
just supposed to be uh
proact
um how would you say unboundedly
proactive aggressors
uh you would just come back and yeah why
would there be an issue you know I just
I did the thing that I did the thing
that I'm supposed to do
um so speaking of that actually has
there ever been have you ever discovered
or could you imagine a situation in
which proactive aggression
was selected against
in any animal
um
well
uh if you take uh our two closest
relatives chimpanzees and bonobos
the uh you can make two strong claims I
think first of all that bonobos have
much less proactive aggression than
chimpanzees
and secondly that their common ancestor
was much more like a chimpanzee than
like a bonobo
and the reason you can say that is that
there's an out Group which is the
gorilla
and gorillas are much more like a
chimpanzee than
psychology
so what that means is that there's
probably been selection against
proactive aggression in bonobo as
compared to chimps interesting wasn't
there something unique about the fact
that bonobos had a female lead
coalitionary self-domestication
root
yeah
can you explain that
why females why not male you've just
we've just spent half an hour explaining
about how the alpha Alliance and the
guys and they take down and so on what
power do women have in a very close
relative of us right no it's fascinating
it's similar and it's fascinatingly
different
uh I think it's similar because you get
the same
evidence of self-domestication in the
bones and the anatomy of bonobos
compared to chimps as you do in humans
compared to our ancestors or by the way
compared to Neanderthals
um
a difference is
that in bonobos you still have alpha
males
whereas in humans you don't have alpha
males in the primate sense
and so the self-domestication that's
happened in human in bonobos
does not involve removing the alpha male
alpha males don't get killed
um and you know we certainly don't have
a really good handle on the dynamic and
bonobos but what you see nowadays is
that when a male gets out of hand
he is not taken down by males he is
taken down by females
so you get a male who
challenges a female over a piece of food
say
and she gives a squeak
um the five females who were closest all
rushed to her Aid and they all go
chasing that male
and he runs off and is is terrified and
rightly so because
those females can impose a lot of damage
you know like any gang they're pretty
effective and they can bite his
Knuckles off or uh give them some nasty
wounds maybe in the end we'll see some
evidence of killing like that I don't
know
so there's something very different
that's going on in the
self-domestication of bonobos from
humans uh it's not directed at
um or the current behavior is not
directed at
um eliminating
the
Tyrant males what it is directed at is
stopping the males from being aggressive
towards the females
what's different why what's the pressure
that's different there
between humans and bonobos
well
uh it may not be the pressure so
different as the ability
so you know you could argue that the
pressure in bonobos might be just as
great for males to take out the Tyrant
male
because and you and that that would be a
very fair argument because we know about
the distribution of paternity in bonobos
and we know that even you though you've
got this sort of relatively Pacific
self-domesticated form
it is still the case that the alpha male
is getting just as high a proportion of
the paternity as occurs in chimpanzees
namely you know 70 in small groups I
mean yeah it's really high
um but what the bonobas don't have is
the human ability
for the subordinated annoyed frustrated
in-cell type males
to be able to get together and attack
the tyrant
I think because of this difficulty of
forming a confident coalition
presumably those those males those
underlings would have the same ability
of coordination and Coalition as the
females though it's not like the females
have something specific that the males
don't that's true what the females have
unlike humans is an ability to spend
time together
on a relatively permanent basis so that
whenever a female is frustrated and
annoyed by a particular male then the
feet they're always females there to be
able to
attack him and that's unlike humans
where uh you know in all societies
humans break up by day and and go off in
small groups and uh and a man can uh
find an opportunity to beat up on a
female uh when there are no females
around to to support her I suppose as
well being Patra local at least on
average where you know the woman perhaps
gets married off to the husband maybe is
displaced slightly geographically away
from kin
kinship us use my help and then in
addition you know there's the fact that
um once you've got the alpha Alliance
who have already shown that they can
kill the Tyrant male then once you have
language any male who says you know I I
was attacked by half a dozen females the
other day you know I couldn't believe it
and he goes and tells his mates then and
all of a sudden you've got a very
powerful male group that can do
something about those females uh
interesting okay so getting back to the
the morality things I think this is
really interesting you mentioned before
that
um men typically throughout history have
come up with uh some would say arbitrary
and Fantastical Solutions and excuses
for why they may be given preference in
certain areas of life does this make the
mythology and the storytelling around a
lot of this essentially just plausible
justifications for what men want to do
yes for what benefits the uh the male
Alliance
um so I think the story of human society
you know major major story of human
society is that it is designed around uh
what benefits the group of males that
have taken power
so they take power from the alpha male
they
um they have a monopoly on violence
uh you know their Monopoly means that
they one of the rules is uh we're not
going to tolerate violence within our
group
um so that leads to a series of of moral
principles associated with that
um
the I think the basically you're right
that um uh that the morality of a group
is uh intimately associated with
uh what benefits the males
as a group
and that might mean that some
individuals are frustrated because the
rules that have emerged out of the the
group
are not necessarily beneficial for a
particular male you know the male who is
the cleverest or the the strongest or
whatever he has to conform to the rest
of the group himself
but from the point of view of the group
as a whole
these moral principles were
for their own benefit and so you know
religions are are of course you know
very male biased in terms of
um
the way they work the um the precepts
that come down from on high you know God
gods are typically personifications they
are
personifications of something and and
what what are the personifications of
well I think the answer is the
personifications of the interests of the
male group a lot of third rails here
Richard first off we've come for
Morality and and cleanly decapitated
that one and then next perhaps the
entire institution of religion at large
as being a a more elaborate storytelling
justification but I can completely see
the logic I can completely see how it
would be the case that emergently there
needed to be a more sophisticated
ethereal harder to refute it couldn't be
something rational it couldn't be
something that was
um provable or disprovable here and now
it can be like the number of of cows
that somebody had killed or whatever it
had to be the the Special trumpet the
magical Trumpet of the gods or whatever
it wasn't that there was something that
you said about a special path if women
walked on a particular path and in quite
a lot of these societies small scale
societies you have areas that are
restricted for males only to use and and
if you emails even even by accident you
know not knowing about them because
they're a new female in the group or
something walk on the mail path then
then they they can just be killed
interesting because it's so important
for the males to maintain complete
control over uh the male
cosmology the male
there was a lot of evidence that you
found for even
um kin kin executions or whatever there
was a story I think of a mother
strangling her son in his sleep because
he'd slept with somebody else's partner
at some point
this to me seems like a very this should
be selected against incredibly heavily
why why would you choose you know in
terms of Fitness adaptation why on Earth
are you going to kill your own son as
opposed to try and take on maybe the
entire it's me and you son Let's Take on
the entire tribe what's your
understanding you're right that this
this is very extreme and in terms of the
ordinary expectations of
um
individuals being expected to favor
their own kin against Nom kin it doesn't
really work but I think it reflects is
the incredible power
of the the dominating group with its
ability to impose its own morality on
everybody else and there may come a
point at which
I know cynical
um
examination of uh or appropriate
strategy would say
if I support my son who has been
irritating others in this group then
he's going to get killed and I'm going
to get killed and all our family is
going to get killed
and it may just behooved me to recognize
that this individual is dragging us all
down and I'll get rid of him and then
we'll all be safe again
the you know the the big picture here is
that the ability to kill the ability of
uh of a group to
develop rules
um that they can enforce
is behind
so many of the complexities of human
society
complexities and and patterns that are
very different from what we see in any
other animal
I think we've just massively
underestimated the extraordinary
revolutionary effect
of the development of capital punishment
it changes all the power dynamics
what happens
when we reach a period of human
development of civilizational
development where we now have a surplus
of resources or actually it is an even
more interesting question
have you thought about what would have
happened how the local ecology the local
resources and mating Market could have
influenced
the response to aggression so for
instance if there was a period shortly
after a a big war with a local tribe
where there was a high female skewed sex
ratio for instance or if it was a period
after an ice age where there was a more
abundant amount of food to go around
have you considered how the
human aggression response might have
been adapted to those kinds of
situations
well not really but but the
the sort of gut feeling I have about
this is that uh male desires male
motivations
um are almost infinite
you know think about the fact that
Emperors in various different societies
around the world uh China India Peru
when they get absolute power
uh you know they're not quite the same
as alpha males in chimpanzees but they
have the power equivalent in some ways
but what do they do
they just get infinite I mean
essentially infinite numbers of females
so you can take hierarchies in these
Empires where you look at the most
um powerful individual man and he might
have a harem of
ten thousand women
and and he acts like a
um a breeding bull where two females are
brought to him every day whose menstrual
periods have been monitored so that
they're most likely to be fertile on
that day logistical nightmare
yes and the and even the Emperors
themselves complained about uh you know
the obligations here but but
nevertheless you know
that's what it can go for and then but
then the you know the vice Emperor
whatever they call you know the the
people under him they get a certain
proportion and then under him another
proportion and so you know all the
people in the government hierarchy uh
have got uh their own uh Rich number of
females the trickle-down effect of
So when you say uh you know well so you
know maybe everyone would just sort of
stop and give up and and uh and make
nice if they had lots of access to lots
of females it seems to be more likely
that what would happen is that that they
would just all be competing for all of
these females again desire would expand
appropriately I so I can see that
absolutely in a post-agricultural world
the interesting thing to fold in was the
first question that I bailed out of
which is there has to be some sort of a
change in terms of how
a tyranny or aggression is treated
when one individual can start to
accumulate far more resources once we
get to the stage once we've got the
Agricultural Revolution once we stop
being nomadic once we stay still for
long enough to actually be able to
accumulate defensive fortifications and
stores of food and all the rest of the
stuff
it seems to me that that would maybe not
be a hockey stick the same as the
introduction of language but should have
made a change to the dynamic of how
humans relate to each other sufficiently
because before that period how many
women are you going to support a hundred
thousand years ago how many women can
one man support realistically yes that's
right and of course um you probably know
what the the famous studies the tiwi of
Northern Australia
where uh you had hunters and gatherers
in general becoming more polygenous as
you went further north in Australia
um and as you go further north towards
the warmer regions uh you find that it's
increasingly possible for women to look
after themselves without any male input
in terms of the accessibility of plant
and animal resources and the animal
resources are generally fairly small
they're sort of lizards more than
um Buffalo
weren't any
um and uh and you had intense
provisionally with the men having say 20
wives
um and the support all went in the
opposite direction to the one you were
talking about that is to say a man would
say oh my goodness you know I'm not
going to get enough food unless I have
at least five wives and you know now I
have 20 then I get lots of food because
the women were supporting the men
[Music]
is that an element of the fact that when
there is a surplus of resources
the requirement for women to date
sub-optimally for want of a better term
there is less pressure for them to do
that because them on their own are more
likely to be
fine they don't need the male protection
in this way
well yes they don't need the middle
support and so you know in contrast to
what you had in Africa uh probably were
uh there were large animals that did
contribute significantly to the economy
and where men were needed to be able to
provide for females in that way
um where that doesn't happen
then
um
uh as it was saying it's increasingly
possible for a few men to dominate
access to the the females and you had a
very interesting system where
um it was the the elders uh were really
quite old like uh you know 40 years old
almost like a gerontocracy type thing it
was very gerontocratic that's absolutely
right yeah relatively few old men uh
they had a hard time of it because
um you know there's no lights of course
so they'd they'd go to sleep go to bed
at home let's have the evening meal
um with uh maybe 25 files for the 25
women that are the wives of a particular
man
and it was all too easy for some women
to go out of the firelight and go and
meet Bachelors uh and get into trouble
that way and so the Bachelors were
supposed to uh to go off a long way
um they were supposed to go and live in
a different part of the Bush for uh you
know 10 years or something before they
were allowed to come back and and be
part of the system at all okay have you
considered
in the modern world
the changing dynamics that we have of
um
peace relative piece in our time the
lack of requirement for men to do both
big game hunting and warfare uh the
condemnation generally of both proactive
and reactive aggression whether that be
socially or legislative
legislatively and also the increasing
female achievement and Independence that
they have from men that in terms of
resources education employment you know
a sperm donor and a good education will
get you a long way in being able to
raise a family without the requirement
of a male have you considered what
the goodness Paradox or the
um approach our Humanity's approach to
aggression looks like in this current
version of civilization that we're in
now
well I agree that it it raises
um questions about male roles and you
know I see all this stuff in the news
about
um
adolescent boys
feeling frustrated that they're not able
to to be as male as their perceptions
would like them to be and the way that
Andrew Tate and his philosophy
uh incredible
appallingly appealing
to to boys
and I agree that it it kind of raises
some really big issues about
um
about the future about whether or not
it's going to be satisfactory for males
to be you know increasingly
um
powerless increasingly uh unnecessary
I I but I've not I've not considered you
know exactly what's going to happen I
mean
um
it's not always easy to appreciate I
think the fact that
the same essential dynamic as you can
see in a group of hunters and gatherers
that is you know 20 people
is I think at play in our society today
in the sense that we have uh moral and
institutional systems that keep violence
uh in its place and if you are violent
in a small hunter-gatherer Society then
you will be subject to a an arrow in the
back
um and everyone will say yes you
deserved it you know or maybe plan it as
an advance and the same happens nowadays
with us if you are too violent then you
will end up nowadays in prison
um and presumably that will lead to a
reduction in your reproductive success
and we all have developed a whole series
of sensitivities to these complex rules
that
um keep us in in control
now you're asking is it possible that
these rules will get so burdensome and
so at variance with our
uh male spontaneous Tendencies to uh you
know do the equivalent of go hunting
um that uh
that somehow the system will break down
I you know I tend to doubt it but but
you know it's uh
it's a future that
that we haven't been to before so you
know who knows what's going to happen I
went for dinner a few weeks ago with
David Buss and I was sat down and I've
been pondering this question for a good
while now
um Richard Reeves who wrote a book
called of boys and men he's a policy
wonk type guy from Washington DC but
wrote a phenomenal book it's very short
you you'd really enjoy it it's called of
boys and men uh just one uh New Yorker
book of the Year 2022 actually and um
I asked the question of David
and his partner who is a very
accomplished social psychologist
um
what you some men
in 2023
really what what role do they have when
big game hunting and coalitional warfare
is outsourced to the state you know in
the form of armies and and law and a
supermarket
really really what role do we have
because we're seeing women outperform
men in education on average they're more
conscientious they have fewer Geniuses
but they also have fewer ADHD uh
autistic [__] members
uh then when you sit them down and you
put them into an office the kind of
knowledge based office work that we have
now also seems to lend itself towards
women's predispositions at least in part
um and now that they are able to achieve
educational and employment parity with
men they don't need them quite so much
anymore
and then the previous roles that men had
that they would have relied on to you
know that Andrew Tate sort of gives a a
little bit of a nod and a wink too
those are no longer required of men
and kind of the the nerfed kiddy version
of that which was
um capitalistic conquering and upward
Mobility or if it was you know 500 years
ago you were commanding a legion of surf
so you were a baron or whatever right
you know whatever hierarchy you choose
to have that was still very easy for men
to dominate
all of those have fallen away now Anna
you know I asked one of my smartest
friends who's thought about intersexual
intersexual Dynamics mating attraction
for what 40 years 50 years something
like that
and he didn't have an answer and I think
that folding in your work around
aggression around where morality may
come from
uh
ads what maybe a uh slightly Bleak but
very interesting new
area of Spotlight onto this
discussion which is that a lot of the
morality that we were
working off of the back of was built in
order to protect some of men's interests
and now in a world during which those
interests have been emancipated so much
that anybody can access them
the gatekeeping no longer works we've
seen the downfall of all of the things
that we spoke about you know whether
it's spirituality with or without
religion you know the the Advent of
scientism the rationalist world all of
this has slowly just chipped away and
degraded at all of the different little
gatekeeping elements that we had that
would keep this going and then the final
uh
decapitation was the fact that women
didn't need mental resources anymore and
yeah I do I'm going to Doha it looks
like to do a debate on literally on
masculinity they want me to be the like
the card carrying traditional
masculinity is under attack and we need
to stop it from happening I'm not I'm
not I'm not convinced that I actually
agree with that position which is maybe
going to make me bad as a uh debater for
that side but I certainly do feel a lot
of sympathy both for myself and for a
lot of other young men who go well okay
definitions and roles within Society
need to change to adapt to what is
happening in the society right it would
it would be pointless for us to all
value a Man based on how much of a
warrior he he is when we're not at War
for instance right so you need to
reflect the roles with the ecology or
with the local environment whatever's
going on right now
but you can get to the stage where you
erode and dissolve and evaporate so many
of the constituent parts of what a
concept used to mean to the point where
it essentially means nothing anymore
where the word masculinity would would
not resemble anything compared with what
it would have done previously therefore
it's basically it's it's a moot point
and we now need a new word to talk about
what men are
um
so yes very very very interesting
Richard I absolutely adore your work I
think this is this is a fascinating
intersection of morality of anthropology
of evolution of psychology of all of the
stuff that you've gone through uh are
you working on anything next can we
expect anything from you soon
I think I'll probably develop the ideas
about patriarchy
um a little bit more and and I think so
the questions that you're you're raising
are are really big you know are really
important about what is the role of men
the one thing that I thought that you
didn't mention just then is uh is kind
of an odd one in a way but um men have
got a tremendous role as fathers of sons
yes uh you know helping to to bring to
real sons because it does seem as though
Sons benefit
very often from having a male father
figure
but um but it's a funny thing that
because the fathers very often don't
know exactly
what it is that they're trying to do
correct in in raising them it's not
upheld it's not high status you know to
be a stay-at-home dad is still not high
status it's not high status for men to
other men and it's not high status for
men to their partner yeah so we also
have this evolutionary mismatch of it
relationships where the woman out earns
the man the man is 50 more likely to
need to use erectile dysfunction
medication it's twice as likely to end
in divorce it's four times as likely to
end in divorce if she contributes more
than 80 of the household income all the
way down
I mean I wasn't literally thinking that
that he has to be a stay-at-home dad but
but just to be to be a dad at all you
know because I mean I think one of the
fascinating uh problems is going to
arise in the pretty near future
is that women are not going to need men
for reproduction
yes
that's that's already that's already
happening I have a friend who's got a
PhD she's a self-made millionaire 37
years old
uh she's done not IVF but whatever
embryo selection sperm donor thing and
she's she's ready to go
so that's that's halfway there but I I
bet you that it won't take many decades
before we don't need swim at all
how would that work what would you do
well uh you know that there are
um there are birds uh that are
parthenogenetic
that uh that have reproduction without
any sperm and it seems to me that people
will increasingly be able to discover
what it is about sperm that is necessary
uh for an egg and it won't be long after
that before we figure out a way to have
two over fuse so we'll be able to have a
baby with each other
um oh wow there's no theoretical reason
why that shouldn't happen
we are racing to we must find a new
thing for us to do Richard or we are
racing toward obsolescence I feel well
yeah but if you think about the species
as a whole
yeah I mean this this gets Fantastical
but it seems to me that ultimately
if you really want to envisage a a
stable a relatively stable future for
the human species
I think it'd be a very good idea if if
there are no Y chromosomes
because you know the the ultimate source
of violence
is the Y chromosome
the women are clearly less given to what
we might call irrational forms of
aggression
than men are
and and I I would think that it would
ultimately behoove us in a world of of
new kinds of reproductive technology
uh for a moral agreement
in whatever kind of social structure we
have in the world uh for the Y
chromosome to be put into a test tube
like smallpox and
um
and for it not to be manifest in
is that ethical to talk about
essentially an entire gender's
Eugenics removal from the future of
civilization
there's a question for you
well we have decided to touch the final
third rail uh just to to leave that
there uh I've never even thought about
that before uh and I have no idea what I
think about it other than I don't quite
like the idea of all men going and and
leaving but I also thought before I read
your book that human morality hadn't
occurred as a byproduct of alpha
alliances so
we'll see uh Richard look I I like I say
your work's fantastic
um when you thank you so much it's my
pleasure when you come up with something
new let's discuss it I would love to
discuss it and if you do end up coming
through to Austin at any point uh David
has told me that we need to go for
dinner so if you do fly through Texas
make sure that you add an extra day into
your trip if people that are listening
want to check out more of the stuff that
you do where should they go on the
internet
um
well I I studied chimpanzees and we have
a a website called kibali chimpanzee
project k-i-b-a-l-e kibali chimpanzee
project and look up the goodness Paradox
Richard I appreciate you thank you
thanks Chris what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]